[Musik]
Armutsquote auf Rekordhoch Inflation und
ukrainekrieg an den Tafeln wird die Ware
knapp wir hatte von jetzt auf gleich
hatte wir über 350 Kunden
dazu gleichzeitig kommen immer weniger
Spenden
Verteilungskampf nach dem Motto
verschwind sonst kriegst du
eine auch die Helfer geraten allmählich
ans
Limit gesellschaftliche Probleme über
das Ehrenamt politisch
abwälst und trotzdem wir können halt
arme Menschen nicht einfach im Stich
[Musik]
lassen Köln Hauptbahnhof auf dem
Bahnhofsvorplatz und der Domplatte
direkt daneben wird Armut besonders
sichtbar es ist einer der wenigen Orte
an denen Obdachlose und Bettler geduldet
werden
morgen morgen dank Menschen wie Jutta
ist es aber auch ein Ort an dem sie ein
wenig Hilfe bekommen Jutta betreibt
eigentlich eine Suppenküche für
Obdachlose inzwischen kommen aber auch
viele andere ich verteil jetzt Nummern
die Nummern kriegen die Bedürftigen
kölnpass und so weiter und die blauen
Nummern kriegen die Obdachlosen okay
warum warum habt ihr da so eine
Trennung dieosen haben sonst keineance
hier durch die Reihe zu kommen die
Obdachlosen sind auch sehr empfindlich
die stellen sich nicht in die Massen
haben die Probleme mit und die kriegen
jetzt extra Nummern die kriegen extra
Nummern weil die zuerst drankommen okay
ja dann immer ich sage immer zu dem ihr
seid die Nummer eins dann lachen sie
dann freuen sie sich ja da ich komme ich
komme jut macht die Suppenküche jetzt
schon 25 Jahre die 74-jährige Betrieb
früher eine Gastwirtschaft nur wenige
Meter von hier sie hatte nie
Berührungsängste mit Menschen die die
auf der Straße leben und sie kennt ihre
Geschichten ich sag arbeitslos geworden
haben sich geschämt das zu Hause zu
sagen die Wohnung verloren die Familie
verloren Frau mit den Kindern Weg das
sind Schicksale
über 370 000 Wohnungslose gibt es
zurzeit in Deutschland die meisten
kommen in Notunterkünften unter aber
etwa 35 000 Leben Tag und Nacht auf der
Straße sie sind obdachlos jeden kann es
treffen sagt Jutta deshalb duldet sie
auch keine abschätzigen Bemerkungen über
sie mir hat einer im Lokal als ich da
war hat mir einer gesagt warst du heute
bei deinen Pennern nein ich war nicht
bei meinen Pennern ich war bei meinen
Obdachlosen wer bei mir Penner sagt der
hat es hinter sich der kriegt von mir
richtig ein drüber das sind keine Penner
das sind
[Musik]
Menschen Obdachlosigkeit ist die
sichtbarste Armut viele Rentner
Arbeitslose und Flüchtlinge leben aber
auch am Existenzminimum wir haben
kölnpass haben also auch wenig Geld
ja brauchen auch Lebensmittel und ich
sag mir immer wer hier steht 2 D Stunden
der Öffentlichkeit preis gegeben der
hat's nötig es würde kein anderer machen
ne das heißt du du kannst einfach nicht
wegschicken nee ne tue ich auch nicht du
hast doch schon
Offenbach am Main die Tafel hat hier
vier Ausgabestellen heute ist die
neusalzer Straße dran Rentnerin heidi
ist immer eine der ersten in der Früh
ist weniger los und man hat noch Zeit
für ein Schwätzchen guten morgen morgen
alles klar guten mor Heidi guten mor
essen sie Fleisch ich esse
fleischinfleisch ja und Gemüse und O ist
wichtig danke schön der Großteil der
Spenden sind Lebensmittel die im Handel
nicht mehr verkäuflich sind sie sind
kurz vor dem
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum oder nicht mehr
schön anzusehen schlecht ist die Ware
aber nicht Heid ist froh dass sie einmal
die Woche ein paar Sachen bekommt denn
obwohl sie ihr ganzes Leben gearbeitet
hat muss die 77jährige schon seit 3
Jahren zur Tafel ja weil die Rente nicht
reicht weil ich Aufstockung vom
Sozialamt
bekomme allerdings gibt's im Moment sehr
wenig da muss man mit dem zufrieden sein
was man bekommt danke schön
Bön bis zum näch
mal obwoh sie kinderen 40 Jahre
gearbeitet hat bekommt Heidi kaum mehr
als 800 € Rente im Monat dazu kommt
Grundsicherung im Alter plus Miete so
kommt die Witwe auf gut 1000 € im
Monat waren ja früher selbstständig mit
unserem
kantinebetrieb und so muss die ja sehr
günstig verkaufen die esse und dann hat
nicht gereicht um noch mal eine private
Rentenversicherung
abzuschließen um die R aufzubessern hat
Heidi bis vor d Jahren stundenweise noch
als Pflegehelferin gearbeitet dazu
brauchte sie auch das Auto dann haben
die eigenen Kräfte nachgelassen jetzt
kann sie sich den Wagen eigentlich nicht
mehr leisten ohne würde sie es aber
nicht mehr zur Tafel
schaffen hier allerdings gibt es immer
weniger zu holen Helferin Helena
beobachtet das schon
länger also ich habe selbst angefangen
während Corona und in den letzten di
Jahren hat man aber gemerkt D es schon
deutlich weniger geworden ist also
gerade jetzt durch die Inflation ist das
was wir von den Supermärkten
bekommen vielleicht die Hälfte von dem
was wir sogar zu Beginn von Corona
hatten wo es auch schon extrem wenig war
früher wurde vom Lebensmittelhandel oft
viel mehr bestellt als gebraucht
hauptsache die Regale waren immer voll
auch kurz vor ladenschloss der Ausschuss
war entsprechend groß heute wird dem
Kunden zugemutet dass auch mal ein
Produkt fehlt das spart Kosten aber für
die Tafeln bleibt dadurch weniger übrig
hier in Offenbach versuchen Sie jetzt
auf anderen Wege an Lebensmittel
ranzukommen Christine Spar ist die
Leiterin der Tafel und hat heute
erfreuliche Neuigkeiten wir dürfen wir
dürfen Einkaufen es ist da es ist da es
ist da es ist
da wir dürfen einkaufen gehen wir dürfen
einkaufen gehen weil jemand hat
mitbekommen dass wir nur noch die Hälfte
an Lebensmittel haben und doppelt so
viel Kundschaft und der hat uns eine
Spende gemacht für 10000 € wo wir jetzt
einkaufen gehen können eigentlich sind
die Tafeln mal gegründet worden um
Lebensmittelverschwendung zu reduzieren
heute geht es immer mehr darum Armen zu
helfen ohne Geldspenden würde hier alles
zusammenbrechen und es wird ja immer
schlimmer guck mal komplett Lidl ist
weggefallen bei uns das hat ein riesen
Loch bei uns reingemacht auch viele
andere Handelsketten verkaufen jetzt
selbst Ausschussware zum reduzierten
Preis oder geben Sie ein Restposten
Aufkäufer für für den Handel ist das
profitabler als die Ware zu
spenden was das für die Tafeln bedeutet
wird wenige Augenblicke später deutlich
Christin jetzt S 11 Uhr wir haben nur so
viel Gemüse und Kartoffel sindenig und
und obs wir haben jetzt nicht mehr bis
die Lieferung kommt die Kunde kommen und
wir haben nicht so an ja halt wenig wre
da ne und wir warten auf die nächste
Lieferung wenn wir Glück habe hat er
mehr wenn Pech habe ist es ganz wenig
und es kommen nur vier F Kissen dabei
raus und das muss jetzt halt auch
reichen ne das schlimm weil du musst
halt jedes mal sagen tut uns leid wir
haben nicht mehr wir haben nicht W wir
haben nicht mehr wie jetzt bei mkerei
aus wir sind auch fast leer aber das das
war's für heute das ist halt der
Nachteil wenn du eine kleine Tafel bist
wir haben nicht so viele Märkte hier uns
fehlt der
Lidl den Bedürftigen bleibt nur zu
warten in der Hoffnung dass noch mal
Nachschub
[Musik]
kommt cotbus kämpfen die Tafeln mit
ähnlichen Problemen immer mehr
bedürftige und immer weniger zum
Verteilen Anfang des Jahres musste
Geschäftsführer kinuak zu drastischen
Maßnahmen
greifen wir haben die Notbremse gezogen
bei uns ist es so 130 Karten am Tag
temporärer Aufnahmestopp mehr geht im
Moment einfach nicht und damit ist gut
Danny ist davon nicht betroffen er kommt
schon länger her eine schwere Erkrankung
hat ihn in die Armut getrieben ich habe
keinen rechten Unterschenkel mehr
aufgrund von Diabetes und aufgrund
dessen kann ich im Moment erstmal nicht
arbeiten seitdem bekommt der 45-Jährige
eine schmale
Erwerbsminderungsrente
sie meldet mich jetzt an und gibt mir
eine Wartenummer ja genau jetzt setze
ich mich vorne hin und warte bis die 79
kommt bis er aufgerufen wird hei erstmal
ein bisschen Zeit mitbringen erstmal
Zeit mitbringen aber das bin ich schon
gewohnt danke schön bitte Danny bekommt
830 € Rente damit es fürs
Existenzminimum reicht muss das
Sozialamt noch 60 € dazu geben so
bittechön trotzdem kommt er ohne die
Tafel nicht über die Runden und es ist
fast die einzige Gelegenheit für Ihnen
unter Menschen zu kommen wie lange
kommst du den schon hierher seit di
Jahren komme ich jetzt schon wöchentlich
einmal
her zum Inventar oder ja
genau für seinen tafelbesuch Danny 3 €
als Spende abgeben nicht für die
Lebensmittel sondern für den
tafelbetrieb also Miete Fuhrpark und den
Sprit um die Lebensmittel
ranzuschaffen tschüssi tschüss die
meisten tafelbesucher sind dankbar dass
sie für kleines Geld Lebensmittel
abholen können aber wenn es immer
weniger für den Einzelnen gibt kommt
auch nightid auf Streit uninander ist
vorprogrammiert deshalb bedienen sie in
cotbus verschiedene Gruppen zu
unterschiedlichen Zeiten
natürlich muss man aufpassen dass keine
verdrängungswettbewerbe stattwinden ja
also wir versuchen das wirklich alles so
zu
trennen dass wir den handhabbar werden
ja also wir haben spezielle
Öffnungszeiten für Rentner wir haben
spezielle Öffnungszeiten für Menschen
die arbeiten gehen das alleine ist schon
krass genug dass jemand der arbeiten
geht auf die Hilfe und Unterstützung
einer Tafel angewiesen S ist und wir
haben separate Öffnungszeiten im Prinzip
auch für geflüchtete um das alles ein
bisschen zu
zernen und gewisse
Stressfaktoren zu vermeiden und ja die
ehenamtlichen Helfer erleben viel die
erleben dass in bedürft ja auch mal
reinkommt und hier sein Frust ablässt
sie erleben aber auch wie ältere
Menschen vielleicht stehen Tränen
fließen weil sie es einfach nicht
verstehen dass sie nach 40 Jahren Arbeit
auf die Hilfe und Unterstützung von
sozialen Einrichtungen angewiesen sind
auch bei Juttas Suppenküche geht es
manchmal raau zu dürftige geraten
aneinander aber auch Helfer werden
beschimpft dann muss Jutta durchgreifen
aber das kommt selten vor mit
Herzlichkeit regelt sich fast alles von
selbst hast du schon Nümmerchen dann
komm mal zu mir kriegst ein Kuchen und
dann kriegst du Nümmerchen such dir ans
raus auch Evelyn ist wohnungslos im
Sommer hat sie lange unter einer Brücke
geschlafen doch der näher rückende
Winter macht ihr zu schaffen vor kurzem
konnte sie einen Platz in einer
Notunterkunft ergattern ich habe erst
gezeltet und es war ich krite Panik von
der Kälte
und bin deswegen dann auch in der
winternilfe ganz schön anstrengend ja
bin eigentlich zu alt dafür evely wird
später wiederkommen inzwischen treffen
die ersten Lebensmittel ein die werden
an der Suppenküche nämlich auch verteilt
wie bei einer Tafel auch hier bestehen
die Spenden aus Lebensmitteln deren
Mindesthaltbarkeitsdatum kurz vor Ablauf
ist sogenannte MHD Ware trotz jutas
Organisationstalent es fällt immer
weniger für Sie ab die Milch ist
komplett gekauft und der Joghurt ist
komplett gekauft also das ist jetzt
madwre das läuft ab Semmelknödel laufen
ab dann kriegen wir das G Geschenk da
muss ich aber immer schneller sein wie
die
Tafel die Tafel kommt ja jeden Tag in
die Metro Sachen abholen und ich ruf
dann immer donnerstags in der Metro an
und sag hallo ich komme morgen Zettel
hinhängen an Kühlhaus jter kommt
dann komme ich dann war die Tafel
manchmal früher da und dann haben die
Leute der Tafel schon gegben und dann
stehe ich wieder da Krieg keine MW
kriegen schon viel weniger es sind
eigentlich nicht genug Spenden da heißt
das auch gut deutsch auch ne wenn man
sind nicht genug Spenden da oder sind zu
viel Menschen geworden ja Kön wir nehmen
wie wir wollen aber da müssen wir durch
da müssen wir durch wir müssen im Moment
durch die flüchtlingskrise durch zwei
ganze Stunden warten die Bedürftigen
jetzt schon um einen Teller kommen jetzt
geht's los heute gibt genau Gemüse
Kartoffel mit Einlage
Würstchen und wo kommt die Suppe jetzt
her von Peters Brauhaus der SP das der
spendet das seit Jahren schon genau
macht immer ganz gehal vololle tolle
Suppen auch im Brauhaus wissen sie dass
der Bedarf größer wird damit es für alle
reicht kochen sie inzwischen zwei Kessel
statt
einem 50 und jetzt C
280 Suppe ist genug da allerdings gibt
es Probleme mit den Löffeln wer Suppe
will muss einen
haben die müssen ihren Löffel mitbringen
weil wir kriegen ja keine plastiksache
mehr zu kaufen jetzt können wir so
Löffel kaufen
mit bambuslöffel oder so aber die sind
unerschwinglich für uns jetzt haben wir
unseren Leuten gesagt bringt den Löffel
mit wo ist dein Löffel nächste Mal
kriegst du ke Supp es ist einfach so wir
machen das jetzt mal anders kein Löffel
keine
Suppe aber du schtimst und am Ende gibt
ja doch immer
natürlich aber man muss schon mal
einfach
schimpfen eventuell aber Gnade vor
rechtzusagen gut für die Umwelt hier
aber schlecht füre Menschen
beiedürftiger wnungen
dieungen aber Obdachlose haben meist
kein eigenes Besteck eine Weile später
treffen wir evely wieder für sie gab es
heute nicht nur eine warme Mahlzeit auch
ein paar Lebensmittel kann sie mitnehmen
ja
also Brot von Brot Wurst Milch ein
bisschen was zum Kochen simmelknödel und
Gurken
also die Tafel ist auch imfüllt also ich
nehmen auch keine neuen Leute auf und
von daher bin ich schon froh bin schon
froh dass es das gibt
hier solange bei vielen Tafeln
Aufnahmestopp herrscht hat Evelyn keine
Chance unterzukommen als Wohnungslose
mit ständig wechselnder Meldeadresse ist
sie immer die neue für die kein Platz
mehr da ist auf dem Weg zu ihrer
Notunterkunft trifft sie zufällig auf
ihren Kumpel Peter der hat noch größere
Probleme ein ganz böser Tag gestern
warum alles
weg
nein
ich am am Arsch hab und gestern haben
sie mir mein Wohnung geraubt mein Zelt
mit dem kompletten Inventar von fast
1000 € we ich mir tagtäglich zusammen
Köttel alles weg nur noch das was ich
hier habe aber wer denn also wer das war
Grünflächenamt a das Grünflächen ja ich
tu ja will Kämpen logisch als
Obdachlosen wir können uns kein cing das
nichts erlauben und dann fangen Sie
einfach an und räumen und machen ich
werde nächstes Jahr 70 Jahr alt aber was
machst du denn jetzt ja was mache ich
ich fang wieder von vorne an Evelyn hat
glücklicherweise noch ihr altes Zelt in
der Notunterkunft das will sie Peter
jetzt überlassen dann bringe ich dir
jetzt ein Zelt also ich bringe ihm ein
Zelt habe noch ein Schlafsack das ist
aber jetzt fürügeben erstmal etwas falls
es regnet und so peter ist sehr froh
dass die beiden sich heute begegnet sind
so eine Unterstützung ist nicht
selbstverständlich Kamerad
Wahnsinn Wahnsinn her lebst auf der
Straße nicht of ne nein das ist auch
Glückssache Glückssache was Gutes ja da
lebst du nicht jeden Tag Köln Mühlheim
im Bürgerhaus Mütze ist eine von über
950 Ausgabestellen der Tafel bis zu 130
Leute holen sich hier jeden Montag
Lebensmittelspenden ab eine davon ist
Rebecca sie kommt heute mit ihrem Sohn
Odin dem jüngsten ihrer insgesamt fünf
Kinder hi hallo wie geht's dir alles gut
ja einmal ich gebe hier morgens meine
Tasche ab um zwischen 10 und 11 uh und
dann fahre ich nach also mach du mein
Alltag und am Nachmittag komme ich dann
und bekomme die gepackte Tasche für mich
dann nach Hause das hat den Grund dass
einfach zu viel Leute dann auflaufen und
dann der sozialnight auftaucht und warum
hat der zwei Äpfel bekommen warum ich
nur eine Tomate kann ich da reingreifen
um den Ablauf etwas runterzufahren und
etwas äh ja ohne Komplikationen
durchzuführen den
Alltag wie bei allen Tafeln hat auch in
kölnmühlheim die Zahl der Bedürftigen
stark zugenommen viele Ukraine
Flüchtlinge aber auch viele Menschen die
erst in den letzten Monaten in die Armut
gerutscht sind und das ist ja natürlich
schwierig für Menschen sich wie eine
Stange anzustellen mit einer Tüte ne und
dann äh was sie bis jetzt nicht machen
mussten und dann und dann fangen die an
zu sprechen sagen so wir haben früher
kein das nicht gebraucht ab wir können
nicht mehr ne wir schaffen das einfach
nicht mehr wenn eine Packung 0169 kostet
was vorher 89 Cent gekostet hat dann das
können Sie das das funktioniert halt
eben nicht D suchen Menschen eben auch
Schuldige und fragen sich was haben wir
mit dem ukrainekrieg zu tun und unsere
Aufgabe besteht auch nicht darin dass
wir ideologische Probleme hier an der
Tür mit den Menschen besprechen das ist
die Aufgabe der Politik ne und das ist
eine schwere Situation für uns alle die
Stimmung wurde immer rauer Wut und Frust
machten den Betrieb immer schwieriger
auch inan midelhoff bliebt nur ein
Aufnahmestopp um wieder Ruhe
reinzubringen am meisten ärgert ihn aber
dass die Tafeln von Behörden und
Sozialverbänden als beinahe
selbstverständlich wahrgenommen werden
die schicken s zu uns ohne dass S mit
uns kommunizieren sagen hab die
Kapazität oder gar nicht ne es gibt eine
Liste und D ist hier Stadtteil da ist
die tafelstelle hier Stadteil da Stadil
da und dann kommen die Leute hier hin
und wir müssen dann gucken wie wir das
erledigen aber was sollen wir den machen
soll wir sagen wir machen das nicht mehr
ihan und seinen ehrenamtlichen Helfern
bleibt nur bei den Bedürftigen um
Verständnis zu werben die meisten können
zum Glück nachvollziehen warum es
weniger gibt ja also mir ist das auch
klar dass es natürlich daran liegt dass
es das einfach mehr Bedarf da ist dass
es dass die hohen Preise die Leute auch
hierher treibt also ich kann es ja
verstehen also ist ja auch der Grund
warum ich komme wenn ich jetzt drauf
verzichten W dann könnte ich halt wieder
andere Sachen nicht bezahlen also dann
müsste ich mein Kind also ich mein
Kindern jetzt letztens Eis kauft das hat
jetzt kostet aktuell 1,60 € eine Kugel
also da bin ich fast in schlucken
gekommen ne also aber ich meine ich kann
ja auch nicht alle auf alles verzichten
Rebecca arbeitete früher als
Sozialarbeiterin mit fünf Kindern ist
das derzeit nicht möglich ihr Mann ist
Schreiner kann krankheitsbedingt aber
auch nur wenig arbeiten das meiste Geld
kommt daher vom Jobcenter und Kindergeld
so kommt die siebenköpfige Familie auf
€.
nach der Tafel macht Rebecca noch einen
Besuch in der Kleiderkammer von STT
Antonius die Kleidung für ihre Familie
bezieht sie fast ausschließlich von
hier ja das ist W jetzt was für meine
Tochter die steht total auf
ponchus für jedes Kleidungsstück zahlt
die 40jährige maximal 50 Cent manche
Sachen kosten auch gar nichts also da
bin ich froh dass es diese Kleiderkammer
gibt weil da kann man sich wirklich
durchausut Geld sparen ah hat sie aber
nicht sie muss das nehmen was da ist
okay es ist eine Frage wie modisch ist
das ne genau und es gibt dann auch nicht
immer alles in verschiedenen Größen da
mus halt weiteruchen mit dem Einkaufen
in der Kleiderkammer spart Rebecca
mehrere hunder Euro im Jahr Überwindung
kostet sie das nicht secondh kaufen
viele sagt sie der Gang zur Tafel ist
dagegen schwierig für sie bei der Tafel
ist es schon viel mehr so dass man da
das Gefühl hat so ist das hat was mit
Armut zu tun tun ne also gesagt es hat
es ist so so ein Punkt wo man auch sagt
mache ich das jetzt wirklich ne weil
sieht mich vielleicht auch jemand aber
es ist für die Kinder ist ist mir halt
noch mal wichtig dass für die eher die
lebensmittelrettung im Vordergrund steht
also auch für Sie dass das kein dass das
nicht bedeutet wir sind arm sondern wir
tun was Gutes halt ne hilft dir dir
persönlich der Kniff auch
ja schon schon schon ja doch das macht
schon also wenn man das aus einem
nachhaltigen Aspekt dann macht es
irgendwie auch Sinn und wenn man das
jetzt wirklich nur aus dem Aspekt sehen
würde ich brauche das weil ich kein Geld
habe dann ja zieht ein ja irgendwie
runter ne bei Rebecca zu Hause der
zwölfjährige Aaron und die neunjährige
Runa sind schon aus der Schule zurück
die anderen sind mit dem Vater unterwegs
der nicht vor die Kamera wollte
Poncho wie cool ich liebe Ponchos sag
ich doch ist mein dritter ich weiß
richtig gemütlich auch gefällt er dir ja
richtig toll durch so Einrichtung wie
die Tafel und die Kleiderkammer gibt's
halt einfach die Möglichkeit ja
mithalten zu können mit den Wünschen der
Kinder also auch ne wenn dann so extra
Wünsche kommen die kann man dann
finanzieren und dadurch kommt gar nicht
so das Gefühl auf dass man arm ist dank
Tafel und Kleiderkammer ist für die
Familie auch mal ein Besuch im zo oder
auf der Kirmis drin ohne die Hilfen
wären solche D
unmöglich einen Tag nach unserer
Begegnung am Bahnhof treffen wir Peter
wieder ein paar Kilometer von der
Innenstadt hat er sein neues Lager
aufgeschlagen ich habe notdürftig
geschlafen das ist das was Evelin mir
gebracht hat wenn ich ST nicht gehabt
hätte die letzte Nacht hätte ich auf dem
Boden schlafen
DF Peter lebt zurzeit ausschließlich vom
Betteln Passanten schenken ih
Pfandflaschen oder Geld so kommt ein
sümpchen zusammen mit dem er
einigermaßen auskommt ich mache im Monat
meine 8900 € und dadurch ist ist der
Platz den du gestern gesehen hast so
begehrenswert ich habe schon
Bierflaschen an den Kopf bekommen wer
macht das denn wer schmeißt den
Obdachlose andere Obdachlose Obdachlose
die mir das nicht vergönnen dass mein
Körbchen jeden Tag wächst das ist der
Neid die Missgunst e ja ja also
paustrecht ist am Bahnhof das ist
grausam trotzdem geht Peter jeden Tag
dort betteln eigentlich hätte er
Anspruch auf eine Rente von knapp 370 €
plus Grundsicherung doch dafür müsste
Peter zu den entsprechenden Ämtern gehen
das kommt für den 69-Jährigen aber nicht
in Frage wenn ich zum Amt geh dann ist
für mich ein rotes Tuch weil ich im
Leben zu viel glechtes erlebt habe mit
denen das darf mir keiner antun der
letzte Vorfall hat seine Aversion noch
weiter verschärft nur wenige Meter von
seiner neuen Schlafstätte zeigt er uns
sein altes Lager da ist mein Platz wo
mein großes Zelt stand das war der wich
den man uns gegeben hat zwei Tage vorher
das harte durchgreifen des
grünflächenamts ist vor allem damit zu
erklären dass es hier keine sanitären
Einrichtungen gibt und die Notdurft in
den Büschen verrichtet wurde daher
wurden Zelt und Inhalt zu Müll
deklariert und entsorgt mit dem Abbau
hätte er das verhindern können aber
Peter wusste nicht wohin das haben die
unterzelte
reingemacht nach dem Motto guck wie die
klar kommst wo willst du
hin zurück am Zeltplatz taucht sein
Kumpel Horst auf die beiden kampieren
seit über einem Jahr zusammen in der
Grünanlage der große kommt doch noch
wunderbar du bist gter komm Schulter
ab der hat Backstein drin mit dem Zelt
sind auch sämtliche Lebensmittel
Geschirr und Kleidung auf dem Müll
gelandet daher hatte sich Horst in der
früh gleich zum Einkaufen aufgemacht
aber wenigstens a der
Kaffee du ber guter und bringt mir noch
ein Tast mit womit habe ich das verdient
Vater du bist da gter das Zelt von Horst
wurde nicht entsorgt er war vor Ort als
die Beamten kamen so konnte er einen
kleinen Aufschub aushandeln das sind
Gesetze kann man nichts dr machen ne die
Leute haben sich beschwert ne ich weiß
auch nicht warum und sind hier gekommen
sind das muss weg und mir ich darf noch
bis heute stehen bleiben ne ich ne heute
kommen die nicht mehr ne muss ich am
Montag Weg ma ich das morgen darfst du
keinem erzählen ist eine Katastrophe die
beiden werden jetzt erstmal ein paar
hundert Meter weiterziehen so hoffen sie
dass das Grünflächenamt sie in Ruhe
lässt wenigstens die nächsten Tage eine
andere Alternative sehen sie derzeit
nicht wenn du auf der Straße lebst wenn
du zu zweit bist du achtest aufeinander
du guckst D dem anderen genauso wie mir
dass dem gut
geht und hält
zusammen auf der Straße gilt das Recht
des Stärkeren daher ist Peter und Hosts
Freundschaft etwas Besonderes die
meisten Obdachlosen sind
Einzelgänger wieder in Cottbus
Erwerbsminderungsrentner Danny ist
inzwischen zu Hause angekommen erst mit
dem Auspacken weiß er was die nächsten
Tage auf den Tisch kommt doch in letzter
Zeit ist das Ergebnis eher enttäuschend
früher gab es Wurst Käse Marmelade
mararine hat
nachgelassen Danny nimmt das so hin er
hat in den letzten Jahren gelernt sich
zu
[Musik]
bescheiden z.B gab's vor einiger Zeit
mal diese Gemüsebrühe hier das machst du
dir dann nimmst du ein paar Tomaten
m ein bisschen Salatdressing noch rin
bisschen Gewürze und dann kannst du
davon auch satt werden was mit der
Buttersoße ja ja bisschen Grünzeug noch
einmal schön umrühren davon wirst du
satt früher konnte Danny sich aussuchen
was es zu essen gab auch an den Gang zur
Tafel musste er sich erst gewöhnen ich
habe
anfangs ein sehr großes Schamgefühl
gehabt dorthinzugehen die Hilfe
anzunehmen und dann die Hand aufhalten
das ist so die Phase wo ich immer
gedacht habe das schaffst du nicht das
schaffst du nicht jetzt sind
mittlerweile di Jahre vergangen was ich
auch dazu noch sagen muss ist man geht
zur
Tafel man bekommt immer ein
Lächeln man geht bekommt ein Lächeln und
das ist schon ein schöner dank man ist
nicht Mensch dritte oder vierte Klasse
oder sonst
was vor vier Jahren war Denis leben noch
in Ordnung er hatte einen Vollzeitjob
als Pflegehelfer von dem er als Single
ganz gut leben konnte selbst Fernreisen
waren ab und zu
[Musik]
drin also früer ein Einkommen gehabt von
18 netto und jetzt ja sind 1000 €
weniger oder mehr als 1000 € weniger und
das ist jetzt auch so ein Punkt wo ich
noch zu knappern habe jetzt muss ich das
nehmen was ich kriege auch die
Beschäftigungslosigkeit macht Danny zu
schaffen darum hat er nach und nach fast
die ganze Wohnung in ein riesiges
Hasengehege verwandelt das habe ich
jetzt neu gebaut hier mit diesem Brett
sonst machen sie mir das Sofa
kaputt früher hätte Danny nicht im Traum
daran gedacht dacht sich kleine Hasen zu
halten da lebte er noch mit seiner Ex
und seinem Sohn zu ihm hatte er trotz
Trennung lange ein gutes Verhältnis doch
dann brach der Kontakt ab da möchte ich
nicht drüber sprechen aber es tut
weh warum der Sohn auf Abstand gegangen
ist kann Danny nicht erklären er hofft
dass er eines Tages wieder anklopfen
wird bis dahin bleiben ihm nur die drei
Hasen ist beruhigt also mehr als eine
Katze mehr als ein Hund brauch ich nicht
rausgehen die versorgen sich soweit
selbst na ja seit wie es geht sind nicht
teuer na ich ma das auch ich habe die H
mir auch aus Einsamkeit geholt
armut macht viele Menschen einsam für
sie gibt es bei Suppenküchen und Tafeln
nicht nur einen Teller warme Suppe oder
eine Tüte Lebensmittel Respekt und
Solidarität zählen mindestens genauso
viel
[Musik]